-You were kind enough to send me
a cut of this last month.
This is such
a wonderful special.
-Oh, thank you.
I'm glad you liked that.
-It is you. It is some other
adult guest stars, like --
people like Richard Kind,
Natasha, and Jake Gyllenhaal
-Yeah.
-But mostly it's kids.
-Oh, yeah, it's me and 15 kids
ages 8 to 13.
-And why did you have this ide
to work with children?
-I thought it would be funny
and I had --
I needed something to do.
[ Laughter ]
And Marika Sawyer,
who you know very well.
-Yes, a fantastic writer.
-Amazing comedy writer
who I worked with at
"Saturday Night Live" a lot.
We always wanted
to write for kids.
We wanted them to add kids t
the cast of "SNL" at one point
and have, like, a little updat
that they would cut to.
So they'd go from Seth and Amy
to two kids, remember?
And Lorne was like,
"We're not doing that."
[ Laughter ]
So we had this idea, and then
just started thinking abou
writing kids talking like me
And I thought that's great
So there's some of that.
And then there's
big musical numbers.
You know,
keep people entertained.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-And then we also interviewe
them a lot on camera.
-That is --
I mean, the songs are fantastic.
And I'm not
the least bit surprised by that.
But one of the parts that really
resonates is the kids
talk directly to camera,
you hear your voice,
you hear Rhys Thomas,
the wonderful director.
-Yeah, Rhys Thomas,
our director, yeah.
-America's voice.
And a lot of
what they talk about
is the things they're afraid of.
-Yes, we asked them what their
biggest fears were and then --
-Were you surprised by
their answers?
-Yeah, because --
[ Laughter ]
Do you know, like --
I thought like -- It's 2019.
I was born in 1982.
So, you know, like when I was 7,
everyone was afraid of,
like, tarantulas, you know
-Yeah.
-And I wonder what kids in 201
are afraid of.
And, like, you can speculate
from the news and everything
And a lot of kids are stil
afraid of tarantulas.
-Yeah.
-And I don't know why.
Like, they're really not a thing
you come into contact with
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Certainly not in New York City
I want to point out, this is
everybody at the premiere.
-Oh, yes.
-Which is fantastic.
They all dressed up.
And when I first met you, you --
-Sorry, they demanded
that it be black tie.
[ Laughter ]
We were on set one day in July
and they went,
"Is there going to
be a premiere?"
And I was like, "Yeah."
And they're like,
"With a red carpet?"
And I was like, "Yeah."
And they're like,
"And everyone dresses fancy?
And I was like,
"Alright, yeah."
[ Laughter ]
-I like this because I feel like
when I first met you,
you sometimes looked like a ki
who was dressed up
like an adult.
-Yes. Yes.
-And it's fun to see
what that actually looks like.
-Yes, this was me on an averag
show night, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-What was it like
auditioning them?
-Oh, well -- it was -- it was --
You know, it started off
like 50 or 60 kids.
And we would have --
They'd come in and do a song
And sometimes a kid would --
you could tell like,
"Oh, she might be good at this
type of energy.
So sometimes we'd
assign them a song.
So this very talented youn
girl, Lexie, we told her to do
"You Oughta Know"
by Alanis Morisette.
And we told her parents,
"Could you have her prepar
'You Oughta Know'?"
And she came in and she said
"I have 'You Oughta Know'
to sing by Alanis Morisette.
And we were like, "Great,"
and she's like,
"But just the appropriate
parts," and I was --
[ Laughter ]
I was like, "What?"
And she's like,
"Just the appropriate parts.
And I was like, "Oh!
Yeah, yeah, don't, yeah."
[ Laughter ]
-You forgot.
-I forgot the whole point
of the song.
[ Laughter ]
Then we talked to them, like
just kind of loosely
interview style.
I gave them --
I had a couple of questions.
And then there was one round
of kids where I'd say,
"Fill in the blank --
America has a lot of blank."
And so I'd say,
"America has a lot of...",
And some kids said, like,
"hamburgers."
And some kids would choke
and be like, "Uh..."
And some kids would say,
"people."
And this kid, Alex Bello,
who's very talented,
who's in the special -- I said
"America has a lot of..."
And he said, "Work to do."
[ Laughter and applause ]
-You talked -- I think it wa
your last special about
how you were not going to --
you don't want to have kids.
-Yeah. Do you have any?
-I have a couple, yeah.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Sometimes I do.
Most of the time I'm happy
Sometimes I wished
I'd talk to you.
-Yeah, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
You wish you had more free time.
-You've talked to them about it,
though.
I mean, they must
have been curious.
-One time on set,
we were holding for a while.
And they said to me,
"So you don't want kids?"
And I said, "No, no, I don't."
And then we had
a conversation about it
as if they weren't kids.
[ Laughter ]
They were like, "Why not?"
And I was like,
"Well, my wife and I
really enjoy our time together
And I like having my free time
to do stuff.
And, you know,
I think kids are great,
but I wouldn't want anything
to come between that."
And they were like,
"That makes sense."
[ Laughter ]
They were talking it out.
This one girl went,
"You might like kids."
And I was like, "Maybe."
And she went, "Nah."
[ Laughter ]
And then we were all doing
a shot the next day.
And my wife, Anna, came by set
And she walked in and I went
"That's my wife, everybody."
And everyone went,
"Hi, Mrs. Mulaney."
[ Audience aws ]
And then this little girl --
not little girl.
Wonderful girl, Camille, turne
to me and said,
"Does your wife
know you don't want kids?"
[ Laughter ]